[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce premier journal à 2022 j'en
profite pour vous souhaiter à toutes et
tous une très belle année de la part de
toute l'équipe de tv 78 nous sommes le
lundi 3 janvier voici les titres de
cette édition
face à la flambée des contaminations
quotidienne de koffi 19 en france le
gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures lundi 27 décembre le télétravail
notamment est de retour à compter
d'aujourd'hui il est rendu obligatoire
trois jours minimum par semaine le point
dans ce journal il ya vingt ans le 1er
janvier 2002 la france abandonné le
franc pour l'euro un symbole d'unité
européenne et monnaie unique aujourd'hui
officiel dans 19 pays de l'union quel
bilan vingt ans après et puis la 16e de
finale de coupe de france s'est déroulé
ce week end le club versailles et s'est
imposé 4 à 0 face à la roche sur yon un
résultat historique pour l'équipe qui
accède aux huitièmes de finale de la
compétition le résumé du match dans
cette édition
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre de
nouvelles mesures ont été annoncées
terminé le petit café accoudé au
comptoir avant de partir au travail
c'est aujourd'hui lundi 3 janvier contre
en vigueur l'interdiction de consommer
deux bouts dans les bars les restaurants
et les cafés une interdiction valable
pour trois semaines dans le but de
freiner la propagation du variant au
micron les gérons se montre mitigé
mathilde aussant coup à mon avis
personnel c'est une aberration parce
qu'on peut consommer ainsi rester
pendant des milliards ne pas consommer
de moubarak a fait en 2 minutes 40 cas
de comptoir qui doit s'asseoir ne veut
pas forcément s'asseoir et les gens
préféreront rester chez eux ou rentrer
directement et pour partir plus tard le
matin et éviter car mon café je trouve
ça bien parce que comme ça tout le monde
sait respecter
vers ça c'est bien pour ça les gens me
sympa tous ensemble et c'est en ça
paraît donc tout le monde est ok c'est
bien moi ça me fait beaucoup rire en
fait tout ça mais je trouve que c'est
avancer et reculer avancer on fait trois
pas en avant deux pas en arrière et
c'est pas une nouvelle mesure ces
mesures qu'on avait déjà mis en place
qu'on ait du mal à faire intégrer à nos
clients et maintenant bas il faut
recommencer donc on a du mal à repartir
on a du mal à comprendre tout ce qui se
passe parce que enfin les mesures
changent tout le temps les distances
elle change les jauges change et faire
comprendre ça à la clientèle c'est juste
pas possible en fait et toujours dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire autre mesure
qui prend effet aujourd'hui les
nouvelles règles d'isolement dans le
cadre d'un schéma vaccinal complet si
vous êtes positif vous devez vous isolez
sept jours après le début des symptômes
il est possible de sortir de l'isolément
au bout de cinq jours avec un test anti
génie coupé cr négatif ou encore
l'absence de signes d'infection depuis
il ya 48 heures et si vous êtes
seulement qu'à contacter la quarantaine
elle n'est plus nécessaire des tests de
contrôle sont toutefois demander en cas
d'un schéma vaccinal à un complet par
contre il est si vous êtes positif vous
devez vous isolez pendant dix jours avec
possibilité de sortir plus tôt de
l'isolément au bout de sept jours les
conditions étaient les mêmes que pour
les personnes avec un schéma vaccinal
complet c'est-à-dire tests pcr ou
antigénique est négatif ou absence de
signes d'infection depuis 48 heures et
si vous n'êtes qu'un contact vous devez
vous isolez pendant sept jours également
après le dernier contact avec la
personne en question un test antigénique
ou pcr négatif est nécessaire pour
sortir de la quarantaine plus
d'informations sur le site du
gouvernement
et puis je vous le disais en titre
également le télétravail fait son retour
en ce début d'année et ce en raison de
trois jours par semaine obligatoire
quand il est possible et c'est l'une des
mesures également du gouvernement pour
contrer la vague du variant au micron
ducobu de 19 on fait le point à
d'ailleurs avec vous magali carré
bonjour danseurs vestine merci vous vous
êtes donc la vice présidente de la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises dans les yvelines est-ce que
déjà on peut avoir votre réaction face à
cette mesure qui a été annoncé alors le
télétravail effectivement est une bonne
mesure dans
sow lui mais il faut faire attention au
tissu économique c'est à dire que
lorsque vous avez beaucoup de tpe pme il
n'est pas forcément évident en terme
technique parce que les df des appels
téléphoniques sur un central ou de
décaler des activités à la maison et
puis le nombre de personnes présentes
dans l'entreprise pour assurer ne
serait-ce que l'accueil des éventuels
clients et des appels qu'on pourrait
recevoir non plus compliqué pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises que pour
les grands groupes par exemple tout à
fait de notre point de vue c'est souvent
adaptées aux très grands groupes qui ont
une flexibilité du fait de leur nombre
de salariés faut savoir que les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés ne
sont pas si nombreux en pourcentage sur
l'ensemble du territoire que 80 % ce
sont des toutes petites tpe pme voire
auto-entrepreneurs donc mitigé un petit
peu mitigé surtout sur l annonce de des
amendes ou on considère plus les
sociétés ou en tout cas les employeurs
ou les chefs d'entreprise comme des
partenaires mais comme des enfants à
gronder et à sanctionner au kazoo il ne
serait pas sage justement à ces systèmes
d'amendés on y reviendra dans un instant
juste avant cette mesure est effective à
partir d'aujourd'hui et les entreprises
ont une semaine pour s'organiser y en a
qui s'organise encore ce matin et je
vous propose de découvrir le reportage
dans une pme de voisins-le-bretonneux
c'est un reportage de gregory kane aller
regarder le recours au télétravail sera
rendue obligatoire je dis bien
obligatoire une obligation de trois
jours par semaine et pour une durée de
trois semaines minimum depuis les
annonces du premier ministre les
entreprises n'ont eu que quelques jours
pour s'organiser face au renforcement du
télétravail ce lundi 3 janvier peu de
bureaux occupés dans ce cabinet
d'experts comptables installé à voisins
le bretonneux la pme était fermée entre
noël et le jour de l'an en cette matinée
de rentrée il fallait donc établir les
nouveaux plannings
là on vient de diffuser un mail général
à tous en dit en rappelant les règles et
en disant qu'on allait mettre en place
les trois jours de télétravail
obligatoire demandé par le gouvernement
l'idée c'est ça c'est de pouvoir
organiser une espèce de permanence au
bureau sans que tout le monde soit là en
même temps et or ce que tout le monde
puisse venir un peu au bureau à des
moments où tout le monde peut se
retrouver aussi au moins entre on
travaille en binôme donc lisez c'est que
les binômes puissent continuer à
travailler ensemble sur le site de saint
quentin en yvelines l'entreprise compte
25 salariés
la généralisation du télétravail n'y ait
pas problématique avec un système
informatique et digital qui rend l'accès
à distance possible l'expérience des
précédents confinement a permis de rodé
en la matière on avait déjà fait du
télétravail à 100% lors du premier
confirmant donc pour nous ce n'est
qu'une
une remise en place du télétravail
on avait gardé une journée par semaine
pour tous les collaborateurs et en est
qu'on est un cabinet à ses tournées dans
le digital ça ne pose pas de problème ce
que tous les collaborateurs ont accès à
distance et ont accès aussi bien aux
logiciels qu'aux pièces comptables pour
encadrer l'obligation les contrôles
seront multipliées selon le gouvernement
chaque sociétés contrevenantes s'expose
à 1000 euros d'amendé par salarié
magali carrés dont convient de voir
l'exemple de cette entreprise un ce
cabinet d'expert comptable qui a mis en
place le télétravail j'imagine que vous
avez un peu eu des retours là dessus
est-ce que c'est compliqué pour les
entreprises encore de s'organiser pour
le télétravail ou est-ce qu'elles ont
pris l'habitude il ya une forme
d'habitude mais aussi une forme de
lassitude pour faire des rimes et il
faut savoir aussi que selon la
population à laquelle on s'adresse là on
ne parle plus de taille de l'entreprise
c'est il ya un phénomène d'isolement
qu'on ne peut pas nier vous prenez deux
catégories de personnes des personnes
qui ont un plus petit logement mais qui
ont deux activités complètement opposées
l'exemple d'une jeune femme que je
connais juriste donc des horaires
traditionnels son conjoint dans la
restauration je vous laisse imaginer
même si la cuisine pourrait être fermée
pas là pas de chance c'est une cuisine
américaine donc on n'a pas trop le choix
que de s'installer dans la salle de bain
pour avoir un bureau et travailler en
horaires décalés
le deuxième est et le deuxième exemple
ce sont les apprentis on a énormément
travaillé sur une jeune une solution et
là vous avez en fait des jeunes qui
découvrent le monde de l'entreprise car
un quart comment voulez vous vous
attachez à une entreprise si vous ne
pouvez pas y passer du temps comment
voulez vous apprendre si vous n'y pas
assez patent et surtout rappelé que les
étudiants ne sont pas tous dans des
super colocation ou chez leurs parents
donc la connexion internet est difficile
est-ce qu'ils ont le matériel et puis
pouvoir aussi rencontrer du monde c'est
important le lien social aujourd'hui
aussi puisque vous êtes en train de dire
c'est qu'on ne peut pas loger tout le
monde à la même enseigne faut faire
parfois du cas par cas finalement ce que
le télétravail n'est pas fait pour tout
bon tout à fait je voulais voir avec
vous aussi parce que vous en parliez
brièvement tout à l'heure c'est une
mesure obligatoire on l'a dit pour les
entreprises sous peine de devoir payer
une amende notamment de 1000 euros par
salarié les contrôles également vont
s'intensifier vous disiez finalement est
ce qu on fait confiance aux entreprises
ou pas est ce que finalement c'est un
peu du contrôle abusif quel est votre
ressenti là dessus pas du contrôle
abusif parce que si on rappelle la loi
la mise en place du télétravail c'est
d'un commun accord et si le télétravail
est faisable donc aujourd'hui si j'ai
bien révisé il me semble que c'est
l'inspecteur du travail qui avec son
carnet va pouvoir sanctionner mais je
vous pose une seule question qui est ami
au mieux de savoir comment fonctionne
l'entreprise à part le chef d'entreprise
comment évaluer la mauvaise volonté d'un
chef d'entreprise de ne pas mettre en
place le télétravail et enfin finalement
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
est-ce que nous sommes partenaires ou
est-ce que nous sommes juste des
justiciables vis-à-vis du gouvernement
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les chefs
d'entreprise quelle que soit la taille
quel que soit les confédérations se soit
le medef l'a ces pme on a tous travaillé
ensemble et d'autres qu'on fume et
d'autres et d'autres partenaires mais on
a tous travaillé ensemble pour essayer
d'avancer ensemble donc aujourd'hui
vouloir nous sanctionner c'est un peu
une forme de mépris de la part du
gouvernement et c'est un petit peu mal
vécu
je comprends tout à fait ce ressenti je
voulais poser notre question par rapport
à ça selon waskul télétravail c'est une
perte de productivité ou pas du tout
finalement ce qu'on est à distance yale
cela dit ça dépend des activités alors
je pense sincèrement pour avoir lu
différents articles jeunes
incrimineraient aucune profession mais
si vous voulez vous avez deux façons de
fonctionner le télétravail au départ
fait une hausse de productivité mais
ensuite la charge mentale on va parler
d'un cadre presque idéal de d'une
personne ni homme ni femme mais qui a
qui travaillent à la maison il va
pouvoir se connecter quand elle veut
elle va prendre une pause repas plus
courte parce que finalement elle va
rester dans son job et la charge mentale
va augmenter parce que sur leurs deux
pauses qu'elle va prendre son café elle
va aller lancer la machine décongeler
les plats ou commencer à préparer pour
le soir ou prévoir de la liste de
courses est en fait si vous voulez les
sas de décompression qu'on a quand on
fait les trajets ou quand on dissocie
nos deux vies professionnelles et
personnelles là il n'y a plus de sas
donc c'est aussi une charge mentale qui
augmente selon et si vous augmentez la
charge mentale forcément la productivité
peut baisser donc ça fait penser un peu
du cas par cas encore une fois si j'ai
bien compris et selon les métiers
effectivement vous avez vous avez une
hausse de productivité énorme et
d'autres pas du tout une dernière petite
question plus globale brièvement avant
de vous quitter l année 2000 21 a été
l'année de la reprise si je puis dire
avec l'arrivée du variant au micron est
ce qu'on peut craindre une rechute
économique
se projeter lorsque vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et quel que soit quelle que
soit la taille de l'entreprise s'est
fait en fonction d'éléments tangibles et
de prévoir ce qui n'est pas prévisible
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'a pas fini
de nous donner l'ensemble des mesures
chaque semaine vous avez des mesures qui
vont changer
l'adaptabilité je crois qu'on a tous
compris l'agilité la souplesse tout ce
que vous tous les maux qui sont devenus
à la mode aujourd'hui sont importants on
a besoin de prévoir et je vous avoue que
la baisse de moral
un sondage est paru ce matin sur le les
français ont le moral mais sont fatigués
et c'est vrai que il est important de se
dire que ceux projetés ça devient
difficile
mais il veut les chefs d'entreprise le
front en effet pour ça mais j'ai du mal
je ne sais pas en fait voilà la vraie
réponse et je ne sais pas on va vivre
ses trois premières semaines et puis on
va faire un pas après l'autre pour
continuer à avancer au jour le jour on a
un peu dans le flou comme comme depuis
cette crise sanitaire finalement que tu
as fait merci beaucoup magali carré
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes la vice-présidente de la cpm
pour les yvelines mais
[Musique]
adieu le franc le danemark ou encore la
lire il ya tout juste vingt ans les
français comme de nombreux voisins
européens changer de monnaie pour l'euro
après des débuts balbutiants est inquiet
les 19 pays aberrant utilisent toujours
cette monnaie unique retour sur ses
premiers pas avec mélanie poké un billet
de 20 euros un billet de 10 euros
contre l'us l'air de billets de monopoly
en 2022 la comparaison prêterait à
sourire mais vingt ans plus tôt les
débuts sont hésitants en décembre 2001
les passages en caisse sont plus longs
mais la préparation s'est faite bien en
amont dans les commerces cette grande
surface avait prévu double affichage des
prix ce temps d'euros et qu'elle se
réservait en fonction de la monnaie
utilisée
les
on a fait d'abord tout ce qui était
formations dites commerciales pour ce
qu'on appelle le basculement de nos prix
en euros sepa ces semaines 44 c'est à
dire fin octobre ça c'est la 1ère partie
la deuxième partie c'est toute la
formation qu'on a fait sur nos hôtesses
de caisse dont qui a duré à peu près
depuis le mois de septembre c'est 600
heures de formation pense pognon mais là
je crois mais bon c'est pas grave à
montigny le bretonneux en ce 1er janvier
2002 le passage officiel à l'euro s'est
fait dans la douceur et chacun avait mis
en place leurs propres techniques pour
ne pas se perdre cette boulangerie avait
notamment installé un convertisseur
s'ils le voyaient penserai toujours
obligé de retourner ça pour qu'il le
voyait tout alors bon là comme ça ils
voyent ce que j'ai fait au plan pratique
c'est j'ai un porte-monnaie pour les
héros et entendent mener pour les france
il vous fallait à partir de là ça va
premier achat en euros mais aussi
premier retrait les commerces sont
fermés mais certains saint quentinois
découvre cette nouvelle monnaie je
n'avais pas de kit j'avais rien acheter
je suis quelques pièces en mai mais
c'est tout pourquoi j'ai entendu ce
matin par curiosité oui en fait tout à
fait oui pourpre en avoir pour le moment
les banques notées une ruée dans toute
la france le 2 janvier plus de 2
millions de retraités et effectué les
français avaient jusqu'au 17 février
pour échanger l'an dernier francs et
vingt ans après comment les yvelinois
viril avec l'euro j'ai l'impression que
le passage à l'euro
a permis d'augmenter les prix de façon
exponentielle avec mes études où je suis
allé à l'étranger donc ça va bien aider
en plus avec les banques qui sont à
ranger entre temps pour éviter qu'on a
des prêts supplémentaires ou ce genre de
choses ça va mal ça va mal et des
cantons a acheté notre maison c'était en
francs et maintenant pour savoir en
euros il faut faire le calcul vous dit
tiens c'est plus dur quoi en 2002 comme
en 2022 l'augmentation des prix est la
première inquiétude s'ils ont bien
augmenté les salaires aussi les chiffres
de l'insee ou de la banque mondiale
montrent que l'inflation est restée à
des niveaux très bas
2022 débutent eux tout juste cette année
de grands événements sont au programme
et des projets importants devraient
émerger sur le territoire quels sont les
grands rendez vous à ne pas manquer le
point avec les gorille canal et
2022 année anniversaire à versailles 300
gens du couronnement de louis 15 et
surtout les 400 ans de la naissance de
molière jean baptiste poquelin est né le
15 janvier 16 122 la ville va rendre
hommage au dramaturge exposition dès le
15 janvier à l'espace richaud en
attendant le mois molière qui se tient
tous les ans en juin dans la cité royale
statue en bronze sera également installé
dans le jardin du futur office de
tourisme elle sera inaugurée au moment
de la biennale d'architecturé du paysage
labat deuxième édition revient justement
à versailles du 13 mai au 13 juillet
lancé par la région ile-de-france
l'événement aura pour thème terre et
ville expositions conférences au
programme en 2019 la biennale avait
attiré deux cent mille visiteurs les
yvelinois disposeront d'un deuxième
tramway dans les yvelines après le thé 6
en 2014 c'est le thé 13 qui sera mise en
circulation en juillet la ligne reliera
en 30 minutes saint germain en laye à
saint-cyr-l'ecole les rames d'une
capacité de 250 places emprunteront le
réseau ferré déjà existants et de
nouvelles voies des essais sont
effectués jusqu'à l'été en septembre les
élans courtois et maurepas siens
pourront en profiter le centre aquatique
intercommunal caste alias sera inauguré
à la rentrée 2022 cinq bassins dont un
lui dit qu'un en extérieure chauffée à
28 degrés ouvert toute l'année le
complexe est situé en lieu et place de
l'ancienne piscine de maurepas coût
total 24 millions d'euros
le paris-nice 2022 devrait partir des
yvelines en mars pour la treizième année
consécutive un partenariat lie le
département à l'organisateur à etsaut
jusqu'en 2025 le parcours de la course
au soleil sera dévoilé le 5 janvier en
2021 saint cyr l'école est moins vive
sur mansion été ville départ de la
compétition cycliste pour la deuxième
fois de sa jeune histoire le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste c'est du 12 au 16 octobre
prochain en 2015 la france s'était
classée première avec 7 médailles dont 5
en or devant un public bouillant 25000
spectateurs s'étaient pressés dans les
gradins saint quentinois sur les cinq
jours des mondiaux le vélodrome cité des
jo de paris 2024 tout comme la colline
d'elancourt théâtre des épreuves de vtt
les travaux de la piste olympique doit
démarrer à la fin de l'année et durer
jusqu'en 2024 long de 4 km le parcours
reprendra une grande partie du tracé
existant en 2025 l'espace sera ouvert au
public après de nouveaux travaux enfin
côté travaux à retenir également cette
année toujours l encours premier coup de
pioche prévus pour le futur commissariat
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines situé dans la
zone des quatre arbres ouverture en 2024
le début de la rénovation urbaine du
bois de l'étang à la verrière avec en
première étape la réhabilitation de 400
logements 200 appartements seront eux
démoli en 2024 le lancement de la
construction de la passerelle piétons
cyclistes entre poissy et carrières sous
poissy un ouvrage au dessus de la scène
de 300 mètres de long 5 mètres de large
qui sera accessible en 2024 ou 2025
enfin l'enfouissement de la nationale 10
va se poursuivre toute cette année à
trappes et d'ici 2023 un nouveau
giratoire sera aménagé au carrefour du
pavillon bleu c'est la deuxième phase de
ce chantier d'envergure qui va durer
jusqu'en 2028
du football à présent avec à la coupe de
france et un match crucial pour eux le
versailles de football club l'équipe
jouait ce dimanche en 16e de finale
historique en coupe de france bixente
mairie incendie steban vous êtes avec
nous bon soir bonsoir retour sur ce
match avec vous oui donc tout et ja pas
de suspense justin 1/16 historique pour
une qualification historique du fc
versailles qui jouer son destin face à
la rejoint des clubs de nationale 3 soit
une division en dessous et versailles
ont donc su faire respecter la
hiérarchie une victoire nette 4 à 0
devant les 2000 spectateurs du stade
mondron youssef chebbi l'entraîneur du
club nous explique comment s'est passée
la rencontre
donc il a fallu il a fallu que les
joueurs se mettre dans une bulle c'est
ce qu'ils ont très bien fait et au fur
et à mesure de la rencontre notamment
7.1 période où où les éléments étaient
en notre faveur va être porté par le
public ça donne de la force de l'énergie
la confiance c'est ce qui s'est passé un
match donc bien embarquée car dès la 12e
minute versailles même 2 à 0 grâce à
deux buts de son attaquant christopher
iba le fcv aurait pu se faire peur à la
19e minute puisque un penalty a été
sifflé mais arrêté par le gardien
c'était le tournant du match pour moi
oui on l'a senti dans le set c'était
comme un symbole que tout réussir et au
versailles et la preuve cinq minutes
plus tard avec un petit bijou du latéral
gauche makan traoré une reprise de volée
de 20 mètres dans le petit filet si vous
avez une minute je vous conseille de
chercher le but sur les réseaux sociaux
il est facile à trouver ça vaut le
détour même si vous n'êtes pas forcément
fan de football et donc pour compléter
l'addition un dernier but juste avant la
pause pour sceller le score à la mi
temps 4 buts à 0 donc ça c'était
justement en première mi temps qu'est ce
qui s'est passé au retour des vestiaires
à vrai dire plus grand chose à l'équipe
a su gérer les tentatives d'assaut de la
roche qui ne les aura jamais vraiment
inquiété écoutez un des hommes forts du
coût de cette solidité défensive le
jeune défenseur et capitaine de 22 ans
maël durant de jeu vignes et ses fiertés
clairement parce que ça fait déjà trois
puis quatre ans que je suis là en
seniors
en éclats huitièmes de finale avec
l'aide de cette équipe avec beaucoup
joueur de
ou ces rencontres ans il ya par l'otan
il ya six mois
vous lisez les bichonne téméraire son
site est bonne c'est une qualification
historique pour le club mais puisque
versailles avait déjà connu un 16e de
finale mais il faut remonter en 1947 et
ce n'était pas passé une défaite 4 buts
à 1 contre le fc gueugnon un don c'est
donc à premier huitième de finale le
tirage c'est demain soir du côté des
joueurs on a senti une certaine
motivation de se frotter aux plus gros
je pense au paris saint germain à
l'olympique de marseille notamment quoi
qu'il en soit rendez vous donc le 29 ou
le 30 janvier prochain pour un nouveau
match qui restera quoi qu'il arrive dans
les annales du club merci beaucoup
bixente mais rien senti tebbane pour ce
résumé du match journaliste pour tv 78
plus d'informations sportives à
retrouver dans un instant avec votre
premier magazine sportif donc de cette
nouvelle année et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
meilleurs voeux et très bonne soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]